[Music]
My name is Avinash Singh Rather, but for all of you
I
am Tiger. I have given everything for the protection of India for 20 years. I
did not ask for anything in return,
but today I am asking for your hand.
Today I am telling you all that I am Agent Tiger.
That Tiger is your enemy, how did you know that the
name of India is China, RAW agent, Tiger
is a traitor, one day Tiger will prove to be the
enemy number one, so after 20 years of service,
I am asking for my character certificate from India,
not me but India for my son.  He will say
whether his father was a
traitor or a
patriot, if he is alive then his head will be present in your service, if not
Jai [
Music]
Hind, the tiger is not defeated until the tiger dies.